Westworld season 2 episode 7 reveals
some of the central secrets of the
season Bernard and Ford are inside the
cradle the digital simulation of
Westworld
we learned that the delos company's
secret project is to study guests
behavior and understand the human mind
so that they can make backup copies of
people to make humans immortal they did
this with James Dallas and Ford copied
himself the same way so far these copies
can't survive in physical bodies or they
degrade like James did that's why Ford
got Bernard to put his copied mind in
the cradle where he lives digitally but
James and Ford aren't the only copied
Minds later in the episode
dolorous mentions all the souls gathered
in that valley
it sounds like Della's made copies of
lots of human guests and since copies
break down in the real world Delos is
storing these minds digitally in the
valley so the valley might be like the
cradle but instead of storing host minds
it stores human minds waiting to
eventually put them in physical bodies
you can argue that making cloned copies
of people isn't the same as immortality
James died a hundred times but each time
he did have his memories and he believed
he was James and as william says if he
can't tell the difference does it matter
Ford also explains how Bernard was made
we already knew that Bernard is based on
Arnold Ford's partner who died years ago
but apparently Bernard was created from
Ford and Dolores as memories of Arnold
these flashbacks in episodes 1 & 6 show
Dolores refining Bernard in the cradle
testing him until he's convincingly like
Arnold so this process is similar to how
Delos made a copy of James but Ford says
that while James is a direct copy
Bernard is a bit different to Arnold
he's an original work which must be why
Bernard doesn't break down like James
does and this is the difference between
Ford and Delos Delos wants to make
perfect copies of human minds to be
preserved immortal predictable but Ford
wants to make a new people hosts with
the free
will to evolve and change like Bernard
Dolores and Maeve but Ford says he needs
to take back Bernards free will for a
bit
Ford moves his digital self out of the
cradle and into Bernards head so that
Ford controls but not Ford says that for
the hosts to survive they need to open
the door
which seems to main hosts escaping West
world and the West world Arg hints at
how this might work
it shows imagery of the Trojan horse so
one theory is that Dolores will put the
minds of her hosts inside the bodies
intended for the humans stored in the
valley with human bodies the hosts could
sneak into the real world
like a Trojan horse this would also
solve the problem of the explosives in
her spines the hosts old bodies could be
left behind in the valley with those
empty mines that Antoine finds and for
poetic revenge
Dolores could even put some human minds
from the valley inside old host bodies
to be captured or killed as hosts this
would in a way give both sides what they
want the hosts would be free like humans
while the humans would be immortal like
hosts they'd swap but this is just
speculation what we know is that de
losses plan is to copy and immortalize
human minds and that Bernard is based on
memories of Arnold Bernard leaves the
cradle with Ford in his head Ford makes
Bernard get rid of Elsie who's been
super chill about Bernie's weirdness and
assault
then Ford brings Bernard to the control
room and talks about the burning of the
Library of Alexandria as a metaphor for
West's world he says destruction isn't
the end it's a whole new story in itself
so there's a slow-motion battle -
Beethoven's seventh this season says
beauty in chaos Ford makes Bernard shut
down some systems to give Dolores more
freedom to kill then he forces Bernard
to gun down humans so Ford's plan is the
same as it's been since season one he
wants to help the hosts bait humanity
and become free but while he speaks of
freedom he still controls Bernard four
dramatically died last season but
still hanging around like a force ghost
or a 30 year old at a college party why
doesn't he let go
Ford spoke earlier about God reveling in
his creation meaning Ford wants to enjoy
the world he created before it ends and
he dies dolorous attacks the Mesa hub
she's come for Peter Abernathy because
he's her host father and because his
brain contains a decryption key for the
Delos project maybe it unlocks the
valley beyond fighting against Dolores
our human soldiers they wear haptic
vests that connect to the hosts mesh
network and vibrate when hosts a nearby
like a robot radar but Dolores as hosts
surprised them by wearing the clothes of
dead human soldiers this human disguise
might foreshadow Dolores as hosts using
human bodies to escape Westworld
Dolores wants to destroy the hosts
backups in the cradle so that Delos
can't keep resurrecting and controlling
hosts she sees a tonal life as a trap
and wants the freedom to die like a
human at the same time that humans are
seeking immortality like a host so
angela seduces a soldier whose thirst is
stronger than his will to live Angela
says she was built to please men she
used the same moves on William and Logan
but now angela uses her body for her own
purpose she Nick's a grenade and blows
up the cradle sacrificing herself to
make the hosts mortal irreplaceable and
free of course killing all the backup
hosts that live in the cradle raises big
ethical problems but welcome to West
world
clementines shot down Teddy 2.0 kills
Coughlin and Dolores confronts Charlotte
before finally reuniting with Peter she
wants to save him and to extract the key
from his head but in the end she can't
have both
so she rips the brain from her father's
head apparently killing him so just like
with reprogramming Teddy Delores
sacrifices the people she loves for the
sake of her war hopefully the bloodshed
will be worth it
William and Maeve both run from ghost
nation and meet in a home
William thinks Ford programmed ghost
nation to bring them here but ghost
nation might have their own reasons for
arranging this reunion Maeve remembers
the time that William killed her and her
daughter
so for revenge she shoots bill and eases
her voice power to make Lawrence's
cousins also shoot him lawrence turns up
to protect Bill so Maeve uses her voice
commands on him but they don't work
apparently because Lawrence is awake and
conscious
so instead Maeve makes lawrence remember
all the times William killed him and his
family
Williams done terrible things to
Lawrence over the last thirty years
so Lorenz shoots bill who is somehow
still alive
Maeve frames this as a choice for
Lawrence just like she let a carne and
Musashi choose but Maeve only gives
Lawrence this choice after her voice
control fails Lawrence's cousins don't
get a choice
so does Maeve only give free choice to
the hosts that she can't control anyway
cuz that's pretty [ __ ] what may have
really cares about is her daughter who
is suddenly captured by ghost nation
which is weird because previously ghost
nation has captured humans like Stubbs
and Emily and Lee why capture Maeve's
host daughter maybe they just want to
lure Maeve akechi des says she's meant
for the same path as him we'll learn
more next episode just as ghost nation
arrives della security shoots down Maeve
and Lawrence this is the team Leigh
called for help he tries to save Maeve
but this attack is his fault
Lawrence is left for dead maybe for good
and William is left with four bullet
wounds he's gonna need a real good
health pack maybe his daughter Emily
will help him Maeve is taken to the Mesa
bleeding and near-death then Dolores
turns up victorious in her battle it
seems like Maeve's philosophy of freeing
and loving hosts has lost while Dolores
is philosophy of killing and controlling
hosts has won Dolores acknowledges that
her way is dark but she says it's
necessary to survive
Dolores offers to kill Maeve to spare
her from the humans that Maeve refuses
she made a promise to save her daughter
so maybe love
win in the end Lee is hiding in the
shadows he might fix Maeve and help her
find her daughter and Delores rides off
she's got the key ready to enact her big
plan at the valley but Bernard Ford and
Elsie want to get to the valley first
and William also seems headed there
though at the moment he's bleeding
that's the latest we know of the past
timeline most folks are either shot or
headed to the valley after this we know
that the valley floods and strand
arrives and Bernard wakes up on the
beach and then we get to the latest part
of the future timeline where Charlotte
and strand take Bernard and Stubbs to a
secret lab this is where Ford made
Bernard kill Teresa last season and
strand wrongly accuses Stubbs of the
murder
it's a weird old plotline to bring up
maybe it's just an excuse to find this
secret room full of Bernard bodies these
are old versions of Bernard one has the
old-style mechanical face but maybe Ford
used several of these at once
many Bernards make light work but the
point is that Charlotte realizes that
Bernard is a robot and she thinks that
he knows where Dolores took Peters brain
with the key so Charlotte tortures
Bernard with a digital simulation of
waterboarding Delos has a whole library
of virtual tortures for hosts by the end
of the episode
Bernard tells Charlotte that Peters
brain is at the valley beyond which
seems obvious if the key is connected to
the Delos Project in the valley is this
the big secret strands been grilling
Bernard about all season stranden
Bernard would just add the valley in
episode one so now they're going back
also there's this flashback of Bernard
picking up Peters brain and it's not
clear where and when this happens so the
future timeline is still mysterious we
don't even know what's happening in
Bernards head is Ford still in there
controlling him why is his mind so
fragmented and did Bernard really kill
all these hosts will finally get answers
in the valley so the pieces are in place
for the season's end game Dolores is
ruthlessly killing her foes and her
friend
to win her war against humans Maeve is
also killing a lot but she says she
cares about freedom and she wants to
save her daughter Charlotte and strand
represent human hubris and brutality
which used to be William's job but he
might now have a hope for redemption
through Emily Ford is the Creator God
watching the apocalyptic fireworks he
lit and Bernard mostly just wants people
to stop [ __ ] with his brain it's
about freedom and control God and love
legacy and memory and maybe in the end
it'll make sense thanks for watching
please like and subscribe and thanks to
the patrons including Daniel Ahmadi
Elizabeth Mary Leslie Valencia Nordic
Ben King Jeffrey Stanovich and Willy's
Cheers
you